I was happy to have been able to bring
my sister and my mom to the the
telecasts and they and the event with me
because the movie almost famous is about
their relationship in a lot of ways and
my mom would say to me do you know what
you're gonna say I was like no because
I'm not gonna win and you must you must
lower all of your expectations to the
point where this is the highlight right
now us being here okay it's not gonna
get any more exciting than this own it
okay who's we're not gonna win our
category came up and Tom Hanks came out
and announced the the nominees and I
always just died zero nervousness
because I knew we're gonna win and and
it was just wild to see Tom Hanks saying
your name I have a problem with public
speaking anyway so I just felt relief
and happiness and then he said my name
and the Oscar goes to Cameron Crowe's
and your world tips and all of a sudden
you're hearing applause and a band is
playing and everybody's turning to look
at you and my total white heat - fear of
public speaking got dwarfed by what's
going on
and remember standing up and walking to
the steps and Russell Crowe was standing
up and going yeah that's like that's
wild and I walked up these steps and
there's Tom Hanks standing there and Tom
Hanks you know the Pope of the Oscars
and in that moment he saw that terror
was now starting to flood through my
brain what was I gonna say and what
happens next and this guy is Tom Hanks
been through it so he sees this look and
and here's what he did he took my hand
and he said in the calmest voice you
could imagine he said I'm really happy
to be the guy giving you this award way
to go now what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna keep this envelope and give it to
you in a second but you're gonna turn
around you're gonna say a few words and
then I'll just meet you on the side of
the stage
and I was so comforted I just got a look
at him said ok and I turned around have
no idea what I said except I know I did
a little shout out to Billy Wilder
Christie Audrey and Billy and thank you
so much everybody
and all of a sudden kind of like sound
and reality came back and there was Tom
Hanks by the side of the stage and he
handed me the envelope and said told you
wasn't so hard was it
and then he was on to the next and Julia
Roberts walked past and it was like wow
you have an Oscar